okay so we're just starting from here
okay so I am going to move to my range
okay out of his range and out of
personal weapon range
okay and the embon this is the embryonic
one stop moving okay just there cuz I
stopped moving got
it my body my foot my
Center my my intention is oriented to
him not to the weapon do you guys see
that do it
again on Boom you move to him the weapon
is on the left Y Line the shoulder line
no not outside okay my elbow is on that
left Y Line too no
okay here and then it comes straight
down Boom the qu
turns okay
then
up and
in nice and
slow
move
up down P
turns
up in
boom down all the
way
boom
in come to this
side one my right
[Music]
hand is under my Center not here
okay
up
in you
see
boom
down
up
in okay try it
again couple of things to you people
here watch the teacher's technique I'm
not going like
this he's faster than me go go and I go
like
that you have to have a angle of
incidence that's moving from what you're
guarding to the max of what you want
guarded so my weapon comes up this way
you see do it again it's not going here
not mov moving here go and I try to beat
him he goes up boom back okay my right
hand is on my left hip don't have it
over
here St over here down it
goes don't drop the tip don't pick up
the
hand
down when you come
up guard your body
no
here in he
goes have some sense of being behind the
weapon boom behind the weapon boom hop
behind the
weapon
okay try it again he gives the opening
and I go boom he comes down I absorb I
follow it back up as he slowly starts to
ski I lift it up and I enter
straight and
hit oh
absorb he comes in I lift it up I enter
when he entes
boom
boom start with the weapon down give the
O put it on big toe straight
give the opening bring it up my Center
Line
boom boom we enter against each
other okay try it okay again he
goes boom down I go up I want you to pay
attention to something right as he
clears my weapon that's what I want that
contact right there
I don't look for the contact rewind the
film
okay I just follow the Y
energy he goes He clears it it's right
there
okay slow
boom
in right there that's what you want
right there that's I'm going to stop you
here there should be no
Gap right
there okay got it all right here we go
when you make contact you have to adhere
okay so I go here yes that's where it is
okay but I'm not going to be do you feel
how slippery it is just keep coming
forward you see it's going to match his
y
value so that he gets
[Music]
stuck
the guy I'm sorry the guy's running at
you so stop
him okay match the Y value and get that
thing to
stick I'm not doing
anything get it to stick
okay so we are going to rotate around
that
point one nice and slow
two three like I keep it and
I
boom keep it slide
up enter
project
keep it slide
[Music]
up okay
try and that stick there okay got you
can't take it
off
nor can you leave it on but it's
slippery it's going to you have to stick
so we'll go
slow
boom that feeling you
see I he he can't push forward do you
feel that look look at his skin so you
can see okay
no skin you see his skin I'm sticking on
it okay so I keep the stick you look at
his skin I I'll get closer so you can
see the skin you see it skin is turned
turn it won't turn anymore I leave the
stick and I come in without this without
taking it
off do you feel that with your skin okay
one
Bo right there you see it it's going to
wrap his skin
around
so that's as far as I need it to go I
don't let it come back stick I move in
boom we'll do it again close
up there's your initial stick and now
watch his skin came back I need that
skin to be there there there it's there
I move around I never took it
off okay try